allons-y armes blindée cavalerie
pour certains il n'avait pas répété
depuis 30 ans la fanfare de cavalerie du
501e régiment de chars de combat est de
retour pour le week-end de l'ascension à
rambouillet une cinquantaine de
musiciens retrouvent leurs instruments
thierry bergeaud a commencé en 1983 en
tant qu'instrumentiste il est passé de
chef de pupitre pour arriver à adjoint
d'autres dates majeures trente ans après
30 ans pour les plus jeunes on a
l'impression de les avoir quittés il ya
deux semaines voyagent juste un petit
peu de vacances et hop on les retrouve
et puis hop on repart tous les réflexes
sont là on retrouve vraiment eu un vrai
sens de transfert de carolis surtout
celle du 501 parce qu'on avait quand
même 1 1 sont enfermés 520 et puis
d'ajouter c'est pour moi un grand
honneur en tout cas cette fanfare avait
à l'époque une renommée internationale
elle était composée de 80 % à pied et
20% d'engager avant d'être dissoute en
1994 elles participaient tous les ans au
défilé du 14 juillet à paris elle était
souvent statique devant la tribune
officielle elle joué pendant le défilé
des chars des douze blindés sur les
champs-elysées et en 89 en 1989 ils ont
fait une évolution sur sur l'esplanade
en fait sur la place de la concorde
devant la petite bouffe le après trois
répétitions en région depuis jeudi 26
mai les musiciens qui viennent de toute
la france répète dans la salle patenôtre
rambouillet au programme un répertoire
pur cavalerie mais aussi de la fantaisie
sur scène trompette de cavalerie cor
trompette basse ou encore un ensemble de
percussions ça prend ça vous prend un
gigot la hauteur ici là ça vous prend
ici parce que ça vous prend aux tripes
menacé
dis moi hier y ait des musiciens qui
avaient petite larme c'est pour dire que
ça ça remue beaucoup la demande
d'ailleurs si la fanfare du sang elle
n'avait pas été ce qu'il a été on serait
pas là aujourd'hui c'est en feuilletant
son album d'armé l'année dernière que
david falentin a voulu reprendre contact
avec ses camarades entendre ils ont créé
un groupe facebook qui regroupe
maintenant environ 120 musiciens moi
j'ai vraiment c'est une idée comme ça je
dois jouer quelques morceaux
son but c'est pas possible c'est un truc
c'est un faisable effectivement ça ça
paraissait irréalisable on ouvre au
maximum et mon intérêt mais là on
acquiert ou jean-louis moi je
vois là on est cinq ans quatre rendez
vous donc samedi 28 mai à 15 heures
place de la lanterne et dimanche 29 mai
à 10h30 salle patenôtre des
personnalités seront présentes comme des
généraux ou encore gérard larcher ancien
maire de rambouillet
[Applaudissements]